[Music]
[Applause]
uh let's bring in albert breer uh monday
morning quarterback joining us on the
program and uh i just saw where albert
breer is reporting that the bears will
entertain trade offers for quarterback
nick foles
albert joins us now uh what do you think
about that where do you think nick foles
could end up
well i i think it's just sort of hard
because of the money um you know but
he's been a really good soldier for them
and so i think they're going to kind of
follow his lead here i do think at one
point the jets had some interest in in
bringing them in and obviously joe
douglas the general manager in new york
was in philadelphia with foals
understands what folds could mean for a
young quarterback
um you know so i think there was some
level of interest there i don't know how
much interest falls would have been
going to new york right now and i don't
think the bears
are going to put foals in a situation he
doesn't want to be in you know i think
out of loyalty and because again foal's
been a good soldier
um in dealing with the drafting of
justin fields and dealing with the
signing of andy dalton and not getting
very many reps in the spring and in camp
um i think they're going to
either maybe not follow his lead but at
least seek sign off on whatever happens
so it's going to take somebody wanting
to um
wanting to pick up the contract number
one and then number two
i don't think the bears are going to do
it unless it's something that folks
wants to do what about dallas for nick
foles
it makes some sense i mean garrett
gilbert i think would be the number two
there right now and yeah i mean there's
nobody that knows better than the
cowboys what can happen to your season
if you lose your quarterback and you
look at
obviously 2015 when tony romo got hurt
and they had a
really really loaded roster the whole
thing fell apart and then of course what
happened last year
yeah i think the cowboys would be one
team that you would look at and say
could have an interest um if the money
works out could have an interest and of
course you know nick foles being from
texas there is a connection there i know
that uh jerry jones came out recently he
was you know very effusive talking about
tony romo you know his mind first ballot
hall of famer i know a lot of people
laughed at that and said no his numbers
don't compare
uh
is is tony romo should he be under
consideration for the hall of fame maybe
not a hall of famer but under
consideration
i remember like a few years ago when we
had to raise the bar for receivers
because the numbers had gotten so out of
whack right like and so you had like
numbers that were benchmarks for hall of
famers and now guys who hit those
benchmarks aren't getting in because the
statistics have changed
i sort of think something similar is
happening with quarterbacks now where
i mean how do you separate
drew brees from philip rivers from
tony romo from eli manning i mean people
say eli manning's a shoe-in
is he though
like and where do we draw the line um i
think you know over the next five to ten
years hall of fame voters are gonna have
some tough decisions to make on some
guys who
had they been
up for you know induction
10 15 20 years ago might have gotten in
and i think part of it is that we're in
a golden age for the position you know i
you see a lot fewer teams dan just
rolling out there into an nfl season
without an answer at quarterback and we
see that all the time
like you know you feel like 10 years ago
15 years ago you'd see teams that would
go in to a season and the position would
be a dumpster fire and you knew they
were taking one in the top five the next
year and you just don't see that anymore
and i just think that's been the natural
evolution of the position that also
means in the high end
um we've got a lot of really good
quarterbacks i mean the rams moved off a
quarterback they went to the super bowl
with the niners are in the process of
moving off a quarterback they went to
the super bowl with so i just think the
bar is raising at the position in
general and i think that's gonna you
know have an effect on the way the hall
of fame thing goes down too and so you
know it's not just romo in a vacuum it's
also romo versus rivers romo versus
roethlisberger romo versus eli also the
running back position i don't know what
is config is going to be considered a
hall of fame caliber used to be you got
to 10 000 yards and you punched your
ticket to the hall of fame that was a
long time ago i don't know what 10 000
yards means now for is is derrick henry
going to be a hall of famer if he gets
to 10 000 yards yeah in the shelf life i
mean do we have guys who are going to
make it as far as emmitt smith made it
now adrian peterson i think's an obvious
one like you know i think he goes in and
i think that's a pretty easy call
marshawn lynch is he in like if you look
at his career numbers in the aggregate
maybe not but his impact in the game was
huge right like he was the centerpiece
for a super bowl champion on offense
um so frank gore i think huh frank gore
frank gore is a great one franco i mean
i think his critics would say he's a
compiler but you look at his story and
coming into the league with two
surgically repaired knees and making it
as long as he did
um you know and and and having the
impact on so many people around him
being the centerpiece again of a team
that made it to the super bowl in san
francisco
i think it's interesting and i also
think that the way we look at the
position is going to probably start to
evolve and change too i mean you bring
up derrick henry and derrick henry sort
of what the position used to be
you know look at zeke elliott look at
saquon barkley look at alvin kamara all
those guys can bring value in the
passing game and so i think that
position is changing and evolving too
here's the other thing dan i mean i feel
like when you and i grew up the best
athlete on the team more often than not
was the tailback i don't think that's
the case anymore you know i think more
often than not that sort of athlete's
probably going and playing receiver now
like would odell beckham had been a
running back you know if he had come
along 25 years earlier maybe he would
have been marshall fox you know so i
think that that's part of the evolution
as well
he's albert breer senior nfl reporter
lead content strategist for the monday
morning quarterback why all of a sudden
deshaun watson could get traded might
get traded here's what they would trade
for him now it's on the front burner
what because
because because the cut down to 53 is on
tuesday and so the question now becomes
are the texans willing to a
pay him 10.45 million dollars for the
year because that's what it would cost
to carry him on the roster for the year
and b
are they willing to
go with in essence 52 players if they're
not going to play them because you're
not going to play them that means
somebody else is losing their job over
this
and
i just would tell you and like i don't
have a crystal ball i don't know what's
going to happen over the next 48 hours i
do you know i do agree that this creates
a pressure point for the texans to some
degree
i i just you know my sense throughout
has been that nick casario is not taking
50 cents on a dollar for deshaun watson
and and i actually i agree with him on
this 25 year old franchise quarterback
he's got five years left on his contract
there's no more priceless commodity in
football than that and
like because you can't get full value
for him right now
like what's the harm in waiting if you
have them under contract for the next
five years what's the harm in waiting if
you feel like
maybe like three months from now six
months from now you might be able to get
three or four first round picks is it
better to wait and write it out because
you've already written it out with a new
head coach for six weeks in training
camp
um or are you better off taking a lot
less now
and like continuing your rebuild without
watson and without the haul you might
have been able to get
i just unless somebody's going to come
in and offer something the sort of thing
that the texans would have been able to
get in january and february and march
before the 22 lawsuits were filed
like i just think nick casario is the
new general manager of the texans has
resolved not to move it maybe you may
maybe you've got something for me but
like unless somebody's going to give him
the value um that you would normally get
for a quarterback
of deshaun watson's stature absent
everything else is going on which is way
more serious than football what's like
what what would create the the rush to
get something done right now
yeah and from what i'm told though
one team wants contingency plans for
those draft picks and it's like hey you
know what
we'll give the first round picks but if
he doesn't play or he gets indicted or
whatever it might be then those those
number ones become maybe number two is
that you know some kind of language in
there so consider this though dan like
so let's say there's the language in
there and i don't think the texans i
think the texans are leery about putting
conditions on this so let's
let's say
let's say like it like the conde one of
the conditions is he has to play
eight games this year okay
so let's say there's an eight-game
suspension
and which i think is reasonable if you
look at what roethlisberger got in 2010
it was six games that got knocked down
to four so let's say he gets an
eight-game suspension
and then you know
he gets hurt so now he doesn't hit that
eight games right
like
and that takes away a first-round pick
would you want to put yourself in that
situation when maybe it doesn't even
relate directly to innocence or guilt
here it's just sort of the way the
league sees the situation
or would you rather wait for clarity so
you could get three first-round picks
you know like without any conditions on
them um you know the texans i mean if
you if you if you gave nick casario and
david cully truth serum they know
they're not winning the super bowl this
year so is it really that important that
they have the picks right now rather
than in march and by the way they can't
execute any of those picks until april
anyway yeah i mean i just i think if
you're the texans here
like absent everything else like i just
think you have to look at this and say
to yourself
if we're gonna walk away from desean
watson which again like they didn't want
to do in january and february march
before the the temperature turned up on
on everything um if like you're gonna
walk away from that you have to get full
value and if you don't get full value as
a first year gm and a first year coach
for the rest of the time in houston
you're gonna be chasing that back right
that's gonna be the hill you're gonna
have to get over and so
i think you know the texans
you can blame them for a lot of stuff
that they've done the last year that
place has been a mess but i think the
texans are taking the right approach
here in waiting to find a way to get
full value and and maybe somebody moves
over the next couple of days and gives
it to them but i don't think that casero
is going to be pressured into doing
something short-sighted based on you
know a deadline coming up in the next i
guess 36 hours now i mentioned that uh i
thought cam newton was going to be the
starter i still stand by that even
though mack jones has played well played
probably a lot better than people
thought at this you know
lack of experience
cam was only playing two series in this
last game and usually that's what
happens when you're the starter although
belichick left it open though when he
didn't want to name a starter
uh is that some kind of uh hey i got
some coy moves here i don't want to you
know tell somebody who our starter is
there's part of me that says like
because i've seen these situations
before and there's part of me that
wonders
like is he really thinking about it
because mac has played really well that
said um
you have to think about like i think in
these situations you always have to
think about the other 10 guys in the
huddle right and take what happened in
san francisco and you know i talked to
kyle shanahan about this about three
weeks ago and he brought up to me the
idea of doing a quarterback shuttle
right like moving guys in and out
and i know like people went crazy over
what happened yesterday um but the truth
is i mean if you're kyle shanahan and
you're really thinking about doing that
well you got to get not just those guys
ready for it you got to get the other 10
guys in the huddle ready for that too
and ready to go back and forth right
and so i think the same sort of
principle applies when you're really
trying to analyze what's happening with
cam and mac if you were really thinking
about starting mac jones
like wouldn't it behoove you to at least
have gotten him a few series with the
starters in the preseason just to see
what it looks like just so the offensive
lineman can hear his voice just so the
receivers can kind of hear how he
adjusts things and the things that he's
capable of doing on the fly
i mean
in my mind and belichick's a very very
logical person
logically wouldn't it have more wouldn't
it create more value for you to get mac
jones that experience and get the other
10 guys that experienced with mac jones
then it would create some sort of
mystery over who you're starting i would
think so right who's starting
i think it's cam and i think mac
i think max going to start games this
year and i think mac is going to like i
think it could happen quick too
like and i
you know i'm not saying it's
like you know
as quick as it happened last year with
say
justin herbert and tyra taylor and
obviously that's a different situation
but
you know like we've seen this before and
there are like since 2008 which is
really the paradigm shift here um since
2008 when matt ryan and joe flacco were
rookies there have only been three true
red shirts among all the quarterbacks
that have gone in the first round
and those three were jordan love um
patrick mahomes and jake locker all
three of those teams all three of those
quarterbacks played for contenders
that's what's so interesting about the
three quarterback situations in chicago
san francisco and new england generally
first-round quarterbacks go to bad teams
these guys aren't going to bad teams
these guys are going to teams that have
contended recently
so i would say
mac's going to be ready to play
um
either
you know
end of september beginning october
somewhere in there i think they'd feel
comfortable putting them in there i
think the question is going to be how
good are they and do they have the
window to put them in because if cam's
playing relatively well
and they're 3-0 4-1 6-2
do you have the opening to do that i
think it becomes a little bit more
complicated and um you know to me like
that's what's so fascinating about the
situation the patriots are facing and i
think it's sort of similar to what
you're gonna see in san francisco and
chicago too if those teams are able to
get off to the sorts of stars they think
they're capable of also philadelphia
trades for gardner minshew gardner
minshew in his mind
was competing with trevor lawrence even
though he wasn't going to win that job
he's not going to philadelphia to be
jalen hurts back up how do how does this
what's the message being sent here i
think it's the eagles i mean i i think
first of all it's like the eagles are
always carried three quarterbacks i also
think this is just sort of harry
roseman's thing um you know and it goes
back to andy reid it's
we need to give ourselves as many
like throws at that dart board as we
possibly can to try and get the
quarterback position right
and so
i think they bring in gardiner minchu
and they see baseline
for the next few years we have a very
affordable backup and some teams are
paying five six seven million dollars a
year for a backup we've got gardner
minshew for under a million dollars this
year under a million dollars next year
so that's the baseline and if it becomes
more great and if jalen hurt struggles
and gardner minshew proves to be a great
fit for for gardner for uh for nick
ciriani awesome and for all of that
we're only out a sixth round pick and
it's a fifth round pick if he plays so
i just think more than anything else dan
it's
like looking at it as sort of a
risk-reward thing there's almost no risk
um and baseline reward is you get a good
backup at a really cheap rate a guy who
has started i believe 20 games as a pro
already
and maybe it grows into being something
more i'll also tell you this i mean
having talked to urban meyer about it
over the last couple of weeks he loved
gardner minshew as a player obviously
gardner wanted a fresh start somewhere
else but
um you know part of the reason why the
quarterback said you the quarterback
quote on quote-unquote competition
because i don't think it was really a
competition either part of the reason
why
like the the urban had to drag it out
for as long as he had to drag it out is
the guys in the locker room really
respected gardner and saw like the
gardener was actually pushing trevor in
a lot of different ways
always great to catch up with you i
don't know what you're going to do for
the next week with oh you got cut down
like a week and a half that uh
no i'll find a way to keep myself busy
over the next few days albert thank you
buddy all right thanks dan appreciate it
that's albert breer senior nfl reporter
lead content strategist for the monday
morning quarterback